yeah welcome to new video I'll be doing
a couple of blitz games here on ICC it's
a three minute to start and in case I
don't get constant opposition on three
minutes our switch to five also so a
BOGO Indian black him trying to exchange
the dark squared bishop and then set up
boom pawns on the dark square so that he
will be left with a good bishop on c8 so
my idea is to play e5 I could do that
now I could also castle about a5 is also
a good move preventing any before ideas
this is some hmm yeah interesting maybe
a form but this pawn could could be
exposed to I'm not sure
so maybe delay that form move can't be
bad really yeah of course he can he can
try that but I should be quick enough to
UM to cover this yeah she formed to
increase some the pressure on d4
it's possible hard to tell okay well
then I just drop back and come back
every form so I'm
I'm good on the queenside but of course
he's got other ideas f4 was the main the
main the main point probably so maybe I
can put something on the earphone yeah I
cannot play Knight a6 as some then a
four would be hanging this is some
slight nuisance hmm yeah and of course
the time to BM yeah he's playing
everything instantly time running just
banking on its time advantage like with
a five and then nine eight six of course
this is some very slow yeah well I don't
think that this is a huge problem really
can we can go go to g5 but I mean age 45
but it's still a fairly solid the only
real issue is the time
has been he's been quick handled this is
sad this is clear yeah I'm just marking
time I'm not quite sure what to do with
with little time so now he's it's
actually doing something okay
decided to close it just erm yeah this
is just just nothing for white I'm
better now
but the time just in waiting him on the
second rank
he's completely outplayed but of course
timewise it's it's a problem just a
piece up yeah I thought I had it and
yeah I thought that would would have
petrol check but I don't have I don't
have any yeah quite quite annoying he
simply did nothing and to him one on
time this is still still no perpetual
yeah just was just a piece up and
especially g6 is just just terrible he's
dead oh you just wants to play on time
this is possible but after that it's
it's simply nothing for white I've just
after Queen side completely covered and
I've got the edge farm you can try to
get to the edge file and and make a draw
but the way he played he was just losing
but okay I didn't have any time okay so
let's see I need one or two games to
to get to speed I spent spend too much
time here in the opening not really
playing in three minutes Pete yeah let's
see if I get to get a quick new game the
ad was a good clue was really that I
didn't get get a draw here some some
sort of Perpetual I thought that there
would be one but somehow I turned it
didn't work now probably just Ruchi - I
mean blackest black it's just winning
okay so new game and Queens gambit
declined and let's see what's up
variation okay place the the classical
with Bishop d7
just of course very solid yeah not c5
yeah here White has some many options I
always played played this which is
playing credibly fast yeah I haven't
looked at this for ages so I simply
forgot the theory yeah I'm ninety for
some it's a move Howard this is already
a mistake I mean from my side I don't
really remember
yeah a bit annoying especially that he
played this in 19 seconds this is just
great okay yeah I want to get out of the
diagonal here sometimes rookie tuition
as an idea and I hope I'm not losing
them instantly in some way yeah probably
I need to do that it's um it's very ugly
yeah I just need to exchange and try to
make a draw just an opening opening
disaster here and use this 94 idea what
really thought about it too late okay
all this is surprising why wouldn't you
just go back to f6 okay again sent after
Queen g5 I'm I don't have a direct check
out something and it's ripped g8 through
create coming okay so let's let's grab
this first we should be too maybe my it
doesn't have a check right maybe can
play rook g8
yeah look she ate probably but I can
take that on f3 takes on g5 king edge
one can struggle for a draw
it's not not great all this Bishop d4 I
can play rook t1 or t2 and get the pawn
back so oh yeah it's not much fun yeah I
simply didn't didn't pay any attention
to 94 or rather too late now I'm idea I
was rookie 5 a rookie 7 activating yeah
not much I can do can always find one in
and rook takes d5 b5 a problem yeah okay
now we just exchanged hmm b7 it's a
target but it's really not
nothing nothing special at all I cannot
move the bishop because I work g1 mate
need to be cautious about that
but it's and it's very very dry probably
not much happening I can I can just take
this hmm trying to make something of
this b-pawn don't want to promote it
immediately Luke takes d6 threatened hmm
that's probably still it wrong way it's
got only one second I didn't really pay
attention to the clock I try to to get
something on the board yeah all right
yeah at least it's rook Bishop rook and
Bishop against rook at the end which I
can try to win so it's not just just a
time a time thing it's a draw yeah rook
Bishop against Rupert it's a legitimate
to try to win in a tag next game blue
shark and let's play French oh it's a
grandmaster
I didn't think I played him before he
bought all nah he's a veteran GM older
player very sharp player so known to be
a very very technical technical flam
yeah probably on f6 to play Knight f4
okay back then I sometimes played this
kind of setup very I'm very slow
positional playing maybe that's a good
idea against them against the sky yeah
okay he doesn't want a a slow positional
game obviously
so I'm what about this h5 you probably
play f5 right
queen h5 plane on a g3 cannot play how
does it protect the d4 pawn match III I
take the form yeah if you move the
knight I'll take the d4 pawn hard to
believe and I'm not sure how you would
cover it some way yeah okay
it's from hmm
it's still of course rather rather sharp
position but still very hard to believe
that this would be it would be something
for white it's not I don't even I don't
even see a threat coming to get here on
the diagonal and I want to play h5 a
possible age 5 and 9 f5 so Nydia
h5 come on I can play g5 I didn't really
think about G v g5 would have been much
stronger I think this this now looks
very very dangerous for white not quite
sure what I have g5 I have also Knight
f5 and now I'm threatening deform
okay yeah should I take now this is such
a great Bishop hmm yeah of course the
the Queen is hanging and you would
probably take the five okay let's take
it it still should be it should be quite
okay for me with this strong knight on
d5 I got mad f5
I'm just not calculating time warning
let's try to get rid of the Queen's it's
all should be a fairly fairy a playable
position with them as mentioned that
they could night on on d5 and the bishop
it's probably not full compensation but
it's it's still something I mean
controlling this erm this G 1 square so
like I should try okay maybe this is not
so important that she'll try to get on
the G far I he blocked the G far this
was the idea good idea positionally
mm can just take b7 I'm not quite sure
what is what why why he doesn't take it
okay this is a good solution this is
clear
yeah I'm just very much download time I
should have refuted this in the opening
which was certainly possible she
defended defended quite nicely
it's the possible to to put up some
resistance but of course it's a it's not
enough oh it's so know that I think of
it maybe it is just a draw yeah the
position is just a draw yeah no I'm even
winning but yeah I'm okay
yeah of course I must I must refute this
this year is I'm just winning this
position yeah probably here just meets
the Queen away or I just take on h5m
this is probably also strong just I just
want to check this quickly because it's
interesting yeah I can just take it
maybe this is the right solution Jim
yeah computer some minus 2 5 minus 3
something yeah of course I have just won
the d4 pawn and he's got an open King
and but Knight f5 probably wasn't so bad
be surprised that this would be really
really bad night at five and then he
took it he had just retreat down Queeny
7 yeah I was still clear advantage
default so the cleared wanted shout him
as father to spoiled it afterwards
alright so let's try for a new game game
and then whatever I'm doing I'm I'm
doing it too slow too slowly a pretty
good I am here from from France he had
the groom fault
what kind of line should I go should I
go for yeah let's let's play something
something solid Jean or if don't know
this guy
okay let's try for for quite a solid set
up like now usually takes on this c3 and
and on c4 sometimes yeah all this is
also possible the difference compared to
mainline Grund felts is that white has
spawns on c3 and d3 2 to support the
form so the center is not it's not under
under much pressure interesting maybe is
it's really going for b5
some seem strange to me to play b5 but
now he's readjusting what is the idea
Knight takes d4 or something could be
Knight takes d4 and I want to take rook
takes rook takes d4 should be a way to
parry this uh-huh
d5 now it's again playing 94 maybe okay
let's get out of this out of this tricks
on a3 the queen is not so bad anyway
controlling c5 I'm done preparing d5
since nighttime doesn't have any great
squares so defy for the CJ just
retreating aha
interesting maybe night out 95 to c4 c4
b6 something like this the Queen doesn't
have fun too many great squares
can go to the eighth but yeah well
probably you need to okay this is
interesting I thought I could just take
and play night see form empty six is
some quite weak okay let's see what what
is doing against this hmm nothing really
yeah Knight c3 probably at the end okay
I need to take time warning this okay
but he cannot take you five now I just
gotta see it I know I can't the I have
died of this I have this okay should i
win i played this host in such a stupid
fashion yeah at the time i'm just not
this is not my time control if i'm not
played in just spend too much time of
course I was just winning what what can
I say
there was this must must have been just
winning technically okay he'll manage
this white resigns can can look at this
I just need to actually it's just not
possible with this week back rank half
the computer says it's equal interesting
then it's just incredibly lucky I mean
that this that this is saves for black
is just just incredible yeah okay I can
take on f5 and and just draw the game of
course but I didn't did acknowledge this
move
of course yeah
and what is winning g4g for Bishop d7
Knight b6 yeah I came in this cannot be
good really going for this position work
with the pawn on d6 and all those
weaknesses some but this doesn't when a
wounded pawn is quite amazing Bishop e3
here still drawn according to the
computer okay yeah that's that's try for
for one more game what did I do in this
session did I even win a game I won I
won one game at least so let's let's see
if I can get get some some when you
began a grandmaster a pretty good
components here he's playing for some
non non theoretical position yeah let's
let's keep it simple
probably will go for some kind of
hanging pawns not just um I'll just play
it play it safe uh-huh okay this is
quite surprising not quite sure why is
weakening you fall so much
okay let's let's block this first and
then return with a night to e-form
default was hanging but also a sixsome
couldn't couldn't really take maybe
maybe tickle em a bit him on on deform
and then what which is just an
unbelievable move completely killing his
bishop now I can just just return here
and take use of the e4 square okay so
mad if I would would just take and this
is sounds really too little in this
position so ninety-four now I should i
okay let's let's let's put the knight in
there okay now probably this so that
ninety five I can I can just take only
am hoping that I'm not missing a simple
tactic because it's a rather likely that
there is something working because you
look at this position it's quite
remarkable how badly White's pieces are
positioned okay I cannot cannot take try
to get this Knight to c4 yeah okay I can
I can just take it like 25
so I've got them got a safe position now
yeah the light is some dominant on on
before the focaccia Queen trade and I
don't mind yeah just incredible what
he's doing here so just be six maybe
keep it simple time warning yeah he's
playing quickly that's the only thing to
positive to say about White's play I can
say I need to be honest he's just
playing total nonsense and unless I'm
it's maybe are you some time was as
possible or blunder luck here
whoops III don't cover this first and
then take you for yeah yeah of course
just just playing on on some some tricks
yeah it's not working though
yeah the pawn just promotes yeah of
course it doesn't resign checkmate
yeah this was at least reassuring that I
can win a game after after the opponent
is playing really really badly there you
need to look look up who disease doesn't
have a name in there I mean some some
groups are just I just unbelievable for
for forever Grandmaster mean F force
just as just bad and this this move is
just out of this world I mean to get to
allow this kind of setup here put a 3 B
4 C 3 and d 4 weakening all all squares
efore C for a for all the things
weakened and he could have he could have
played 9 f3 I mean it's nothing
spectacular but just covered opponent
and then it's not much happening I mean
I think black is fine because I can
plant a knight on e4 in the long run but
why would you kill your Bishop 3 seconds
it took him and and here probably I
could have ya punished him even even
even harder in some way but it's just
it's just clearly clearly better for
black at this position
all right so at least I won one of those
those games were added at a fine
position yeah thanks for watching